baseball hall-of-famer Jason Stark here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Jason
I feel like I've been floating man for
about a week it's pretty unbelievable no
it's it's funny you you you're well it's
not funny it's it's great it's terrific
but when I say funny it's like it's
remarkable as the better word your your
piece in which your first-person piece
behind the scenes in Cooperstown on
induction weekend I you know clearly
that the honors different when you go in
the Hall of Fame from covering it and
covering it is interesting credible
honor when I did that at ESPN and your
piece talking about the beautiful
Otesaga hotel in Cooperstown it really
is straight out of a Norman Rockwell
painting and they have an event there
we're all the returning Hall of Famers
show up I walked in there and it was
like not at the Museum all the plaques
were alive I couldn't speak I'm
wondering and you talk about that in
your piece I want to give you the floor
and tell people what that was like the
day before everything yeah yeah I mean
it's really exactly the way I felt you
know these guys treated me from day one
like I was one of them Wade Boggs walked
up to me Thursday and welcomed me to the
club and you know I heard those words a
lot but then it was Saturday you know we
were supposed to assemble in a room at
the Otesaga so I could go speak so
naturally I was the first one there I
was my own you know just sitting around
chatting try my best to keep my heart
from exploding from my chest and then I
looked around the room and realized who
was in the room you know Sandy Koufax
was in the room and Brooks Robinson was
in the room and Ken griffeys was right
next to me and I have to admit I I don't
get up will eat my seat and walk over to
a corner of the room and try to take it
all in I thought you know what I need to
take a walk just a breathe I think I'll
walk down the hall of the men's room
just to breathe and so I'm walking and
next
I know there's Jeff Bagwell and he was
great to me all weekend he said
how you doing and I said Jeff I'll be
honest I'm having a hard time feeling
like I am worthy of being in that room
with those guys and he said I feel the
same way he said yeah I have a hard time
sometimes convince myself that I'm a
Hall of Famer the way their Hall of
Famers and it it made me feel better
later was sitting with Jim Thome on
Sunday when they told him that he was
they would like him to sit next to Hank
Aaron on stage that ceremony on Sunday I
saw the look of awe in his face
and so I realized it wasn't just me even
the greatest players who ever lived have
that feeling about guys in that room
it's amazing yeah and then obviously you
know the day that it happens in in that
meadow it's just it really is like I
said a painting the whole thing is just
a beautiful weekend it's just amazing
and I'm wondering what what what of the
day itself on that Sunday will you
remember Jason well you know Sonny I
didn't speak my day to speak with
Saturday Sunday I saw that way I'm gonna
have it easy all I have to do is go out
there and wave but because I was last I
found myself backstage with just a
really small group you know brandy
Holliday was there Edgar was there Mike
Mussina Mariano and you know Mike
Mussina was showing me these notes that
his wife had written out for him so he
wouldn't make a fool of himself out
there and we were laughing about that
and both he and Mariano were so nice to
me we were so complimentary about my
speech and Mariano even said to me he
said you know this is easy for you you
write you play I'm sorry you write you
talk it's easy
we don't write we don't talk we play if
you had to play it
would be hard for you this hard argue
with that right but it almost made me
feel like for a minute he would love to
trade his skillset for my skills he
wasn't sure he could get the words out
now of course you went out there and he
was awesome he was talking I'll never
forget that moment well I mean and
you're you're also a perfect person to
put in perspective of what the day was
like for the holidays you're you have
Philly roots before you joined ESPN for
all those years that I was fortunate
enough to work with you Jason what was
it well can you put into words what the
day was like for the holiday family so
beautiful so sad so special so
heartbreaking it was all of that you
know I my wife and I talked a lot to
Brandi through the weekend and she was
amazing she handled herself with
incredible dignity as she always does
she was really emotional
on Sunday how could she not be but
anytime I've ever heard her speak she
sees somehow finds the right words and I
thought she did again on Sunday as
difficult as that was I was you know I
was in the front row in fact people
thought I was photobombing the you know
that year that Jeter Posada petted Tino
Martinez grew they were sitting right
behind us but I watched her closely they
were showing the video of Roy in his
career and she couldn't watch she
couldn't make herself watch and I felt
for her so much in that moment yet she
was able to stand up and and be so
honest and real about it and talk about
how she couldn't watch could someone
please send her that video sometime I I
thought she was amazing and her kids the
way they handled everything her you know
our son Brayden was amazing he wants to
do what we do rich and then he actually
sat at the podium with her afterwards at
the press conference their you know
their family is is still
strong and holding it together and
that's not easy no it is not Jason Stark
JG Taylor [ __ ] Award winner at this
past weekend's National Baseball Hall of
Fame and Museum ceremonies right here on
the Rich Eisen show do you think Edgar's
admission is finally gonna break
something free for well we know Ortiz
obviously will do that but I mean the
designated hitter sort of bugaboo
letting those folks into the Hall what
do you got for me on that now yeah
I know I do and you know how Baines was
he was a th for the most part in his
career was just amazing travel there to
go through this decade-long debate about
whether a D H belong in the Hall of Fame
and then have them stand up there and
give those speeches back-to-back and you
know it's gonna take just the right pH
it's gonna take someone like Edgar whose
whose period of dominance just as a
hitter is so undeniable that no voter
can ignore it I don't think just any old
D H is gonna go in but you're right he
certainly paves the way for Big Papi and
in in some ways I wonder how he's going
to effect the next Veterans Committee
that considers say dick Allen because
you know one of the things that also
hurt Edgar was he got the big league so
late that his traditional counting stats
didn't seem like they were enough and
yet we were able to look beyond that as
a voting group and realize what he was
for those 10 years in all those years in
a row of 300-400 on days and 500
slugging you know it just doesn't happen
and I you know I if you look at Dick
Allen the gallant did not have the
counting numbers but he does have the
other numbers and so I do think Edgar is
going to cause us as voters to have a
different perspective on number of
candidates going forward and what about
the so-called steroid era what's the
latest scuttlebutt I don't know if
you've ever if you had your ear to the
ground
because your feet were we're not on it
based on your weekend what can you tell
me about it yeah well I mean Barry Bonds
Roger Clemens three elections to go a
couple of years ago I was convinced they
were getting in because of the way their
vote totals had grown year to year and
then what we've seen the last two
elections is they're pretty stagnant and
you know it almost feels like anybody
who was open to changing their mind and
voting for them has already changed it
they're not that far away but are there
and there are there enough votes for
them I'm not sure the ballot has really
opened up now because the number of
candidates that we have elected over the
last couple of years we're about to find
out but it really wouldn't shock me if
they wind up going in on the final year
which I believe would be Alex
Rodriguez's first year oh gosh yeah
right
how about they get half a plaque those
two because you could make the case
Clements seriously Clements had a Hall
of Fame career with the Red Sox and and
bonds had a Hall of Fame career with the
Pirates you could you could make
considerable cases plenty of reasons to
vote for those guys if you're open to it
and you know I've come to this
conclusion that what we should do with
players like that is we should we should
vote for them we should elect them and
then we should let the hall so you're at
how to handle it and the whole thing has
been very happy to stand the background
and let the writers try to figure it out
and put all all the agonizing on us
suppose we ever elect them then they
could figure out I'll own it the best
way to deal with it now that you're in
Jason to heck with it leave it on their
lap man Jason stark here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about the hearing
now this is weird the trade deadline
let's not let's let's not ignore this
has been weird but it's just been weird
on the fact that
had Kimbrel sign late it was weird that
Keuchel sign late that we're seeing
weird things about the market and free
agency we hadn't seen before this is now
the first deadline where there is no
waiver period behind it is what is can
we draw through line between everything
I've just said Jason yeah well I'm I
think a lot of it yeah and this has
really been an odd deadline people
thought that the impact of only having
one deadline and no August trades would
be that everything would start sooner
but instead almost nothing of
consequence has happened yet and you've
got a you've got a really strange
structure in most of these divisions
where the division leaders have really
big leads and there are very few teams
that can look at the Division standings
other than the nlnl central and think
yeah we're going to catch that team but
then you have this whole group of teams
that's two three games out of the
wild-card game and a half out of the
wild card and I think it's creating a
weird kind of gridlock in that those
teams have a really hard time selling
when there are two games out of
contention
right out of a playoff spot but it's
hard to buy when you know your reward
for even sneaking in is you've got to
win that wild card game and then you got
to try to figure out some way to beat
the Dodgers or Yankees good luck and so
those things don't want to buy they're
afraid to sell there everybody just in a
holding pattern waiting for some clarity
or trying to figure out some way they're
going to explain it to their fan base
when they finally do what they do well I
mean the the Giants are a perfect
example right I mean the Giants were
dead and lost bro May and June waters
and now they're on fire they're above
water they're there are two games above
500 you can make the case that they're
the best team in baseball in the month
of July Madison Bumgarner is not going
anywhere with Bochy walking eventually
to the place where you just got
enshrined right I mean that's there's no
chance of him being traded in the next
week would you categorize that Jason I
wouldn't say no chance
but you know there were eleven games
under 500 entering July and now there
are two games over that is just crazy if
that happened and you know I think in
any normal circumstance they'd hold
they'd go for it
you know but just take a step back now
rich why did they hire four hands IET
you know that was a team that did
everything internally there was just a
picture of stability they didn't hire
forehand to keep the band together that
was not the plan
I'm sure there's incredible tension
within that organization trying to
figure out what to do I wouldn't say
never on Matt Baume
it's hard but I wouldn't say never I
would say that if they trade him it has
to be the kind of deal where far hand
can look into the cameras and say how
could I not do this so then which is the
team that offers them the godfather
offer or should let's put it that way
which team do you think needs to make
the Godfather offer from Madison
Bumgarner papa whis is the brains I you
know I think the Braves need a guy that
that fits that profile he'd be really
comfortable there I think they'd have a
chance to sign them and make it worth
your while if they trade for him but
that's the most logical fit for me but
you know he's reminded us now during
this run who he still is he might not be
a guy who marched out of the pen in
Kansas City in 2014 in Game seven but
this guy's an animal
said he's a Pete's and the better your
team is the better he is and the bigger
the game is the bigger the moment is for
him he he loves this he put him on a
good team I think a lot of teams could
dream on that and where it would go but
it it's gonna have to be a big deal big
okay and and name me another big-name
guy that you think could go let's say
the Yankees or the Red Sox or say you
know anybody else at the top of the food
chain
even the Cubs somebody that might
Washington making him
move here to try and yeah yeah I still
think the guy who watches Trevor Bauer I
mean the Indians are there they're
having exactly the same debate that the
Giants are all of a sudden there are 16
games over all of a sudden there's three
games out the division all of a sudden
if the wild-card game were today they
would host it and it's really difficult
for a team like that to sell and yet I
was in Cleveland for the all-star game
and I mean I get the feeling they know
this team as well as its played lately
is not as good as their other teams
they're they're not a win the World
Series team not as currently constituted
if they could make a deal that's the
equivalent of what raised it last year
with Chris Archer I'm convinced they
would do that I mean a team like the
Astros can they absorb him into their
Clubhouse all the drama they've gone on
between him and that team I don't know
but I'd watch them they're looking for
shopping for that that kind of guy
I wouldn't shock me if the Padres came
out of the pack I don't think we live in
an age now where the trade deadline is
all about buyers and sellers the way it
once was I think it's a shopping
opportunity that's how most teams now
viewed your modern front offices and so
now the Indians are smart and creative
there are a lot of teams out there that
could that could buy Trevor Bauer
knowing you have next year too he's a
fascinating piece of this puzzle last
one for you Jason Stark based on last
night's twins Yankees game even though
it's not an all-time situation it was
intense and the twins fans and the
Yankee fans he knew that the loser would
leave he would leave a mark on him
what's the one sporting event of your
life that used the loss by a team that
you were rooting for you still can't get
over to this very day a long time since
I really rooted by them by any sport you
can only recuse basketball family okay
and I I don't think I've gotten over
Keith smart yet that's I have to admit I
can still see the Derrick Coleman
clanking the the free throw and keep
smart hitting that shot
Indiana that's the ones still sticking
in my memory back there you go
well congrats Jason you are a
well-deserving of the weekend in the
honor that you just had to spoke to
bestowed upon you I've known you for a
while and I loved having you on the show
congratulations to you and your family
rich thank you so much I really
appreciate those words I appreciate you
having me on you and I go back a long
time and I treasure our friendship thank
you right back at you at Jason s T on
Twitter Jason stark National Baseball
Hall of Fame right here on the
Richardson show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app